si en europe certains pays sont
particulièrement touchés par l'épidémie
d'autres semblent épargnés c'est le cas
notamment de la grèce avec moins de 2000
cas et près de 80 morts
elle présente un bilan bien moins grave
que ses voisins comment expliquer cette
situation éléments de réponse avec mehdi
escaffit pourquoi la grèce réussit elle
a résisté aussi bien l'épidémie de kovy
de 19
c'est une question sur laquelle s'est
penché cette semaine le quotidien
italien corriere della serra
le journal met en avant une attitude
exemplaire du gouvernement qui a su ne
pas reproduire certaines erreurs des
pays les plus touchés une réactivité qui
aurait fait toute la différence
dès l'annoncé du premier cas le 26
février la grèce a pris des mesures
strictes
les autorités ont immédiatement fermé
les écoles et interdit les
manifestations publiques
un foyer potentiel a été bloqué à temps
mettant en quarantaine un bateau de
pèlerins en provenance du moyen-orient
pour une fois la grèce est en train de
donner le son au premier de la classe de
l'europe du nord
pourtant la grèce semblait être une
proie idéale pour le virus notamment au
vu de sa situation géographique la
récente crise migratoire déclenché à sa
frontière par la turquie pouvait laisser
présager des chiffres dramatiques avec
les portugais les grecs sont à l'heure
actuelle parmi les mieux placées en
termes de bilan humain au sein de
l'union européenne
malgré ces bons résultats une importante
pression populaire le gouvernement de
kyriakos mitsotakis est pour l'instant
opposés à tout déconfinement avant le
début du mois de mai pour en parler